into that let's go to Zagreb with
Maurice Ashley and especially guests oh
sorry we were just chatting here me and
the Ambassador is such an interesting
man I ring down Bakshi who's the
Ambassador from India to Croatia welcome
to the show thank you we were just
chatting and some fascinating things in
your background first of all but let's
let's talk about this event what an
honor it must be to come and make the
first move particularly on the board of
your champion which one at that honor
and you get to play the first move
against him since he had the black
pieces thank God I didn't have to play
the next moves because he's a legend in
our country he's the first Grandmaster
he's been awarded to the high second
highest civilian award of our country
Padma Bhushan he's alleged we grew up
and knowing him I met him many years ago
and I'm embassy when I was posted in
Spain he lives in Spain I went his home
he and his wife and I wonderful to see
him a dream come true I'm ambassador
here and wish Narconon is playing here
and me being invited to the grand
gesture oh thank you all right show your
enthusiasm I can see your enthusiasm for
sure now I know that you have a lot of
passions I read on your bio you're into
mathematics of a degree in mathematics
you love languages you love to travel
photography and all that but what we
want to know is what about the chess
chess was one of my early passions the
reason why it's not on BIOS I'm too
scared to put it in the real top
grandmasters that I hunt I love chess I
love playing it when I have time I love
watching watching it I have
understandings on the moves
it is probably catching I'm not as quick
but schooldays just love playing chess
with our friends sadly that's a passion
that has dropped off a bit now but yes I
see my son now playing he's the
University and he's also playing so
chess is something the India we love
chess and you know we had a historical
another game which is equal to the
parties but Pasha and in our mythology
there is a so I think justice very well
there up in India and it's going to be
even more chests coming with the
Grantchester or going to your birthplace
of Calcutta I am delighted I'm quite
amazed as going there I had no idea I
just got to know
and it's wonderful I think Calcutta
people from West Bengal that's that the
state province of India love chess and I
think you've got a very rousing
reception football and chess are two
things that are very well known in my
hometown so you can start letting them
know now you will find the official
handle of our embassy giving this
information out I had no idea fantastic
we love that and being in this place
with all the best chess players in the
world and no you don't play as much but
you must be additional honor in addition
to having gone on here I agree I agree
it's not just Anand it's a good party
then I love to seeing how how much
camaraderie there is how much you know
and yet they're competing wonderful TC
zone Carlsen here you see Mount Airy
over here we have seen the matric that
only is going on it was it's wonderful
it's quite amazing to see so many top
chess players in one room right here in
Europe
wonderful I'm so privileged and your
your Olympic team and the children's
program sue is so robust there's so many
young stars coming out of India your
pregnant guy who's just regarding us
always you play and of course you're top
players not just on earth yes I think
when I didn't came on to the scene he
was one of the few but what we managed
to do and I think people I am and have
been that kind of a beacon for young
players now we have that knowledge about
Grandmaster people talk so much about it
from our generation and now we have
grandmasters and we have people who are
playing young people and you mentioned
correctly they're doing well of course
the trick is to keep them going at a
professional level and make sure that
they really go to the top where they
know potential takes them hopefully
hopefully cross your fingers that we do
well and first like I think he's kind of
Chester Bob I really what we require are
things wonderful well we're gonna keep
you to your your promises about
broadcasting this event and the event
coming into Croatia thank you so much
for joining us thank you
Irene Dunne Bochy the Ambassador from
India to Croatia you can see his
enthusiasm
he's gonna get some stuff done for us
there in India